okay hello everyone we are going to do a
working session talking about
multi-computation
uh it's theory and implementation
so
first on our list here we're talking
about lazy data structures let's just
understand what we're roughly talking
about here we're going to be talking
about
the concept of lazy data structures and
we're going to be talking about a quite
separate topic which is
uh the granularization of pattern
matching is that a fair statement and
these are not
directly related topics is that true
well they're related because we already
discussed pattern matching and my plan
was
to make this intermediate data
structuring the data structure lazy
for the pattern matching so that it
returns a generator of matches okay
well that seems like it's okay
i
okay
i need to understand i don't necessarily
understand that but let's take a look
here at
um
this concept so
how many lazy functions do we think we
want to have
i mean is it lazy of everything or is it
just a specific set of lazy functions
well at first i i just implemented all
the list functions as a sub value for a
specific lazy list
right
have i sent you the the the list uh what
was it called it was both the thing that
athena made which is
very similar to this and also a thing
that i made a while ago that had a few
more functions i'm not sure if you i've
sent that
um i don't think i've seen yours but i
see nothingness yeah okay well i i
should probably send that something like
that but yeah okay so why are these not
up values now
well the the
the feeling they realize that they wanna
actually achieve with this thing is not
to work because functions list functions
they not actually only work on lists
like they work on arbitrary
heads
and i kind of have one in the same
functionality
for every head that has hold all
attribute
oh yeah but we're not going to have a
lazy version of each function so the
only way to do that would be to have
some kind of a lazy headdress
oh yeah my idea was also like have a
lazy in the packet
like crazy version for each list
also some kind no
no
no if we're going to have this as a
serious thing
that's actually integrated with the
language that's not something we can do
i mean i would just imagine i i mean i
don't i don't think it's a we already
have stuff where for example part if you
give part a quantity array it doesn't
actually extract the part
it
it you know it runs some more it does a
more complicated indexing operation i
mean the same way i think that mapping
over a cons object or something it's
fine if it doesn't literally map over
that expression if it does something
more complicated
yeah i mean it becomes a single point of
specialness so to speak
that there's a special lazy structure
that various functions respond to in a
special way just like you know
just like part extraction does something
special with sparse array or something
yeah yeah but what if i want my own head
that i wanna
like
to make work with these lazy functions
it's like if i have a head that has
whole doll and i wanna use map
in a lazy way and select noisy way
i'm not sure why you
want to i mean like so this is one of
the things that was actually one of the
useful products of athena's project was
just that we tried to think about other
lazy data structures and the basic
conclusion was that it only made sense
to do lazy data structures when they had
analogous non-lazy data structures for
which we already had a bunch of
operations
right if we try to invent some other
data structure with some weird shape
that you know we don't have operations
that that work on it and so it doesn't
doesn't really make a lot of sense and
so i mean i think that basically the
only lazy data structures you end up
having are going to be things like lists
basically in the case of athena we also
have the trees but
but you know what i mean like i i doubt
i doubt there's going to be a hundred
other user generated lazy things that
are substantially different from just
lazy lists
and by the way also
you know lazy graphs already a very
complicated concept because that
involves this whole traversal order
business and so on
if i'm not mistaken
you know yeah
yeah in a way it it kind of boils down
to the generator that generates
something maybe it's ages
right but so the basic point is people
you know one of the things we've learned
is that that
you know in version one
we were much bigger on the idea of
functions
that operate on arbitrary heads
but realistically a lot of people just
use lists for things
one finds oneself just using lists and i
tend to agree that we should build
something that works for lists and if if
we need to
eventually have a general laziness
wrapper
that works for other expressions we
could do that too but the concept that
you have a a raw expression and the
operations then become lazy just doesn't
seem like the right way around
no i don't know i i was just trying to
because now i have a specific case that
i want to work with this is part of
machine and will what for the pattern
machine i actually have two lazy heads
that i want to
treat differently if i just
and it's gonna be
it will do it much prettier if i just
you can use them instead of it's not
gonna be much prettier because you're
gonna have
3000 functions with lazy variants of
them that's not prettier
well it's a
i looked at it like analogous to
parallel
like we have paralyzed
that kind of
just dispatches to it whatever it finds
and paralyzes
we can have a similar thing here for
lazy
wrapper and it's just like let's was a
strict version of gold into a lazy one
well but but maybe two two differences i
mean so for
i mean there are two parallel things
there's functions like there's parallel
eyes and there's like parallel map and i
think i mean the first thing is that
things like parallel map have to be
distinct because their inputs are the
exact same as map in this case the
inputs have you know they have some
special head or something like that um
so you can you can distinguish them
the other thing would be that i don't
think parallel eyes has been
particularly successful
um nobody trusts it
right and it also doesn't burrow in it
only i was surprised by this but
apparently paralyze only looks at the
outermost level so if you have f of map
of blah blah blah and you're
unparalleled eyes of it it won't see
that man it just it just looks at the f
and tries to parallelize that
um
so
well you know that that's just a i mean
that's for roman that's a that's an
implementation limitation
but i don't think anybody trusts it i
don't
yeah you know i think headdress would be
better parallelization is a is a heavy
enough operation
at least in the current state of our
system before we get a parallelizing
evaluator
that you know you're just going to want
to say oh i'm i'm you know
it's it's a conscious act so to speak
so let me just understand what the basic
structure is here so there's a concept
of a lazy list
which would display
i'm confused here i mean so you have a
lazy list
and it might display with a few elements
shown and then the rest of it is just
the symbolic version
of the operations together with the
generator is that correct
yeah like
like the second line with primes
example
like the first one is just only a single
one and then
some of the elements already evaluated
and the last one is just a what is left
over generator
for the next one
okay hold on
so if we just had
the lazy list concept how would that
work here
that would just say
what what are the arguments to lazy list
well it depends what what where is the
list is it con
converting a strict version to a lazy
one no it's it's uh
famous clones there basically
right i mean you get constructors for it
that can construct right i mean just
the function list is not the only way
you create lists right
and and and the function list you know
if we had something analogous for lazy
list presumably it would be like you say
something that takes you know a finite
finite list of arguments and turns into
a lazy list but it's only both finite so
like lazy range or lazy maybe lazy table
right that can take infinities
well in particular lazy lazy table
would look like that lazy table is
arguably like some lazy does not
necessarily mean infinite though like at
least the lazy stuff i made before it
was critically did not have to be
infinite right but so look at it
compared to some
sort of the same kind of concept isn't
it
yeah
it might be worthless
it might be worth making a distinction
though between i mean
again
i i think that these things should have
the exact same behavior as finite lists
except that they happen you know it
happens that you can put infinity and it
will still work
um
so i i i imagine that with something
like like a lazy table you'd either want
to be able to say i comma infinity or
you want to have a function with a
different name from table that just has
very similar behavior
well i don't understand why table
you know i squared
i 1 to infinity
doesn't just work as in why isn't that
the thing no no what i mean by that is
it stays symbolic
and it becomes a lazy list
well that's a different kind of lazy
list though i mean that's a i mean again
this is one of the issues that we have
this is why we don't have any kind of
serious built-in lazy or sorry infinite
you know arrays is that basically
they're they're different kinds of of
lazy slash infinite arrays that we want
for different purposes i mean there's
the leonid style generators and
streaming stuff
there's um which is sort of good for
sort of certain kinds of very
programmery operations
there would be some of those lazy array
stuff we had previous summer schools
where
it's basically you have like you know a
function where you give it a position
and it tells you what the value is at
that position that's useful for all
kinds of like linear algebra stuff and
more more theoretical stuff then there's
stuff like the cons lists which are kind
of more of a functional programming
thing it's kind of in between and you
know
right i don't think there's a single way
that we'd want to do this all right so
so what you're saying is there are list
generators
eg table
range
etc
um array is a list generator
what other list generators are there
there's a list
there's a thing like repeat and column
in haskell that repeaters just repeats
one element infinitely and clone lists
a finite list infinite times
i'd say i'd say repeat is the same as
table of you know x comma infinity yeah
it should let list and nest while list
is a great one
fold list as well hold this can you eat
you know infinite things too well yeah
but but but it is not a primary
generator
sure okay the nest is nestled
fixed point list as well
yeah
right
so these are things that out of hole
cloth unlike fold list
which only takes um
uh
you start out with a list already yes
right so it it it could start with an
infinite list so i mean just to be clear
on this you put math in the same
category like map
sure
sure so i mean
in one of these might be range of
infinity
um
and then we might be able to say fold
list
you know plus onto range of infinity
and that should generate you know
yeah
obvious squares
okay
so there are list generators
so then there are
list queries
of which things like part
well i don't know what their queries
list transformations
yeah transformations and and and
extractors i think are different
but i think extractors on on infinite
lists are often not the most interesting
things
i mean there's some that you need like
arguably you need something like take
that lets you make a you know a finite
version of one although i think the best
way to do is to have take do the you
know take returns another infinite thing
and you call normal on that to turn it
into uh or sorry it turns another lazy
thing but which is finite and you call
normal to make it concrete
but that's a detail probably yes
okay list transformers things like
select
yeah
fold or
bold list i guess
okay listability
that's a very basic one
you know we really have a cantorial
issue of lining up the things if we say
one list plus another list we have to
know that we can line up the infinite
elements
well cons lists can only do finite
yeah
there's another reason for for you know
the why the infinite list stuff is
complicated because there might be
things i mean a bit like the implicit
region implicit set discussion you know
where you have uh you know more than
what aleph zero elements in their
infinite list
yeah
okay
so
again
what do we think the basic design for
this should be
are we
what what is the con that's all i i
don't have any context i mean is the
context this to be a system thing or is
this uh going to be a useful package i
think it i would like to see whether it
can become a system thing
that's the question here maybe it can't
i i still sort of maintain that at least
without very careful naming or something
that
that there are too many different
infinite
infinite array ideas for that that you
know
that only work for one of the like four
applications and so i i i questioned
having a
standard one
okay but but but the other
you know
structure types
we already know their lists their trees
and eventually their graphs
which could be infinite
um
well i mean there's arrays how about
as opposed to like like like matrices
tensors
right which which in general you can
make from from lists but it's much you
know
yeah the question of whether that right
whether it's natural or right whether
it's yes
okay
as well as as well as even more basic
things like how you're representing the
infinite data like is it is it a you
know for example in lots of mathematical
contexts you know you might you might
have something where oh if you give me
an index i can give you the value of
that index i'll just put it into my
formula here
that that's not what this you know these
cons lists do you you could probably do
it but it'd be pretty painful
um
but
yeah just to use another example
okay
like if i want to index into the
billionth position in a matrix specified
like that i'd much prefer it to be a
matrix where you know
it
it just queries the formula then a cons
list that goes the whole way which is
just to say you know
yeah i mean there's just different
applications
right
okay so now this is your version here
yeah this is kind of old but i mean this
is
probably
yeah and it probably doesn't have as
many functions but it's
i'm sure it works in fundamentally the
same way
cons is the basic function is cons here
why does it need that initial one
so the first element is is the value and
the second element is the rest of the
values so it's effectively a linked list
so that that one is saying the first
element of con of this list is one and
the rest of the elements are
ones
is this recursive definition a natural
way to do this or not
or is it better to have something which
looks more like a you know a recurring
decimal or a or a um
i mean it would have been better
i think this is a it's natural that
you're able to do this but i think
obviously if this were some sort of
built-in thing you'd probably want to do
something like we said earlier with
table of
one common infinity or something like
that
well fundamentally
that's the most natural way and which is
the most natural way the recursion
version
and then all the functions that
generating wage list is just doing
recursion
underneath it
i am skeptical i'm deeply skeptical of
that
i think that there are many different
kinds of recursion and you have no idea
what all the structures are and there
are no equivalence theorems for them
well sorry cliver recursion is very
simple
it's like all the tables all default
lists all the definitions of lazy
functions they defined using recursion
which actually leads to some problems
because there's some there's some dollar
occurring limit things that i'm not sure
you can really get around
but i'm i'm saying that i do not believe
that giving people the idea that you can
define an infinite data structure
routinely by recursion is a good idea
because i think the only ones we're
going to be able to deal with the ones
that have been defined to be essentially
very linear infinite structures for
example
right i mean i think i think like look
at some of the later examples because i
think most of the examples i don't like
if you go up a little bit more most of
the examples i don't start by by making
a variable like that it'll be something
more like it
sorry if you go up a little bit there's
an example like you know yeah there's an
infinite nest list right
where it's uh you know it's nest listing
and i think after you know this is some
you know i think this is like the the
babylonian method for computing square
roots or something
um which is not actually babylonian it's
just called that
um
but
but right but then you see you know you
can query it and
actually sorry sorry the thing that says
nest list of you know hash plus n over
hash it's near the top i mean that that
would be an example
i see that's an infinite nest list
right
so do all of these operations like map
do they always return a cons
yes the only thing that the only way you
can get something that's not a cons is
basically by calling a normal
see i am much more of a believer i i do
not believe in this recursion definition
of things i i think as i say i think
that i claim and maybe james or somebody
can i claim you can construct one of
these paris harrington sentences and god
knows uh what else you can make some
kind of weird hydra creature you can do
all kinds of things for that kind of
recursion it's extremely hard to
untangle
and i don't think we should sign up to
be able to do that
am i am i wrong
i'm not really sure what you mean i mean
well because i claim okay let me give an
example
uh
if i
um
this weird thing i'm pretty sure is
definable quite easily by recursion
oh in fact this is a recursive
definition here
what what's your point i mean
my point is that
you very quickly get into things that
are undecidable by doing this
yes i mean but you know the whole
language is undecidable you hope
yeah yeah i realize that but what i'm
saying is that what we want to do is
maintain things that are
clean like a linear loop you know a
thing that just keeps looping forever
and it's just one loop i think we can
deal with that by the time we sign
people up to be able to have arbitrary
bubbling collections of loops
i think it's really hard so the point is
that there isn't though because you're
you can only have
it's it's always going to be some kind
of
well
right the recursion is very limited
because it's just a two argument cons is
you know as a convention is always a two
argument thing
no i realize that that's repositional
recursion yes i understand that i'm
arguing against
setting these things up by saying x
equals black on or x
because i think that's sure i mean that
that will work and it should work well
for that particular case but if i have
seven x's in there arranged in different
ways i have them interacting with a y
and a z and so on i'm pretty sure i can
rather easily construct a very hard to
untangle set of recursive functions
no doubt but i mean this is this is you
can already do that i mean that's sort
of uh it's just if the question is
whether the convention should be that
you should write things like that then i
would agree probably not yeah but it's
better to have an explicit
thing yeah i mean i think it sucks it's
nicer to write something like cons you
know cons range or whatever you want to
call it fine than it is to uh yeah
that's what i think then just to have
the implicit
uh definition where you essentially have
to solve the equation to get the
structure
all right so what is it that we're
talking about here so you've already got
something with this notion of lazy range
yeah actually in this notebook i think
it's called cons range that lazy range
is another thing i made i was comparing
it to
oh
okay but but so
how many new primitives do you need in
this way of doing it where it's a data
structure first
way of setting things up
and i think in this notebook i only had
i think
one new set like one new function which
was the cons range function
um well you also have cons itself i mean
this thing here yeah yeah there's
there's i'm talking about constructors
for four cons right for infinite lists
um i think range was the only one other
than a kind of slightly bad repurposing
of nest list of a two argument best list
okay but the question the hypothesis
here is
i'm pushing back very hard against
having a lazy version of all these
different functions
and i'm much
you know my initial take is it's much
better idea to have a single
lazy list lazy constructor whatever it's
called um
uh
i don't know
right i mean the point is just that you
do need to have a different you know
function name when the inputs are going
to be the same like with range
yeah
well
i don't understand range of infinity is
the way that you get the thing that
we're talking about here
finite you might want to finish khan's
list these things are not necessarily
infinite
and i think it's important that they're
not necessarily infinite because it
means you can do things like you know
you can run take of 100 on them and get
one back
well you think you can get one but i
mean what about the idea of having an
extensible list
and if you want to get a length 10
you know we say extensible list
well if you say take
you know one of the questions is if you
say take range of infinity comma five
do you get back an extensible list or do
you get back an ordinary list
you know do you get that
because this is what you're calling us i
think you should get back an extensible
list and you should only you know it's
like a sparse array
okay the range of infinity gives an
extensible list
and that this gives back
an extensible list
okay
or an implicit list or whatever we want
to call it what should we call it
i mean i think the real thing is it's
lazy
i just i'm not a big fan of that
name but okay we can we can have that
for now
okay so assuming we have a function
called lazylist what else do we need
i mean
how would we get
again though i mean things like array
and range
you probably need to have
um
well why why not just say range of
infinity because you might want to again
because you might you know
you can have finite lazy lists and so
you might you know
unless you want to restrict range to
only construct the infinite ones and
then and then you don't really have any
good way to construct finite ones well
you do a take on a range
if it's a very minority case a take on a
range seems not completely crazy
i guess so
it's less clear when you have a
two-dimensional one
uh
i don't quite know how that would work
and what happens if you have a
triangular array
and i guess there's ways to handle that
as well
yeah with laziness you really never know
what shape it is
let's unless it's expanded
right
yeah hold on guys i'll be i'll be right
back just a second
i'm sorry i'm back um
okay where were we
um
so the question here is
can there be a single lazy thing
where all these other functions have up
values relative to that thing
and i believe
go ahead i was just saying yes as long
as the inputs you know look different
right you couldn't even actually define
up value
yeah
well okay so but nick
the technology you have would it work
with this
well it kind of does already
it's like
so that they have the separate functions
that work places doesn't matter it says
we can just
dispatch
the sub values to those
okay fine
okay
also a question that
the actual
head cons can be can also have flat
attributes
which are also trying to do
what women
can we be specific we're talking about
lazy list
do we also think there's a lazy tree
that's needed
yeah the trees and the also the least
there may be two versions of least flat
and without flat attribute
why
why because i think
having the cons that have a flat
attitude which is also you can be useful
for what
the trees i think are totally different
thing i mean i think that's for
right for representing data that
that is shaped like a tree
um
i mean it's very natural to do also i
mean you can just make something it's
like lazy tree has the same argument
structures tree
and basically works in the same way
um
and
i'm not sure we know enough about what
how that worked what they'll be used for
i would say we
we have
basically lazy tree it's called nest
tree except the only operation that's
supported is root tree like you can
construct so many levels
but the basic idea of nest tree
is that you have a function that gives
you the children and you have a function
that gives you the data
and using that how do i do that how do i
make that
so the first argument is the function
that gives a list of children so just do
like two slot
you know whatever
okay
and then the second argument is the
initial
expression so like one
the third argument is the number of
levels
and then the fourth argument is the data
actually
do like comma h
right so right
in the fourth argument
sorry the first and the fourth arguments
correspond to tree children and tree
data
and that gives you a lazy description of
a tree
and what nest tree does is samples that
out to three levels
right but i guess the
the key word is samples right i mean
like for example with the athena's
project that the point was like she she
made exactly the same thing where it's
sort of an infinite i forgot what it was
called but it was sort of like an
infinite nest tree where it's the same
thing except you don't say three you
know you just you don't tell it how big
to write it same thing
and then i could imagine pre-map and
tree extract just working on that
because the tree extract code like right
now has to do things like extract the
children
right when that contact would mean wait
until that moment to apply that function
and presumably wouldn't have to generate
the whole tree in order to do so and and
also you'd be able to you know have that
you know symbolic lazy thing you could
map over it you could do whatever and
and so on i mean i in many ways it's
it's not quite i
it's not as useful i think as the list
case in part because
with the tree case
there aren't as many structure
transforming operations like with lists
you can do super useful stuff by running
for example select
because then until you run something
like select uh you know if you're just
kind of recalling map and replace and
whatever these functions were
fundamentally all the arguments stay in
the same spot you don't need to generate
the first n arguments you know first n
minus one arguments in order to get the
ends it's only when you start calling
things like select you have to do things
like that but with with tree it seems
like it's there aren't really as many
operations like select and so
it's the laziness isn't as valuable and
also i think just
i mean
i i think less
lazy trees and ideas just come up a lot
less and so i'm not sure you know well
okay what application i have in mind is
it would allow for like so for example
you could take xml and convert it into a
tree using expression tree do operations
and then convert back into xml using
tree expression if you had the lazy
version you could just do the operations
from xml to xml
without having to construct the tree
while still doing all of the effective
tree operations
okay but a different point is that
this question about
you know
you might have end up with the depth
first branching down the tree being
wanting to be constructed and other ones
not
just like for nest graph
you know we have exactly this issue we
could make an infinite nest graph as
well
but that's more complicated because the
evaluation front is not so obvious
does that make sense i mean like like if
i could have an infinite combinator
expression right yep
um
i mean there's clearly value
in being able to do operations on these
infinite combinator expressions for
example
but i agree the first step here is
laziness probably
um
so just to be clear
the way this would work is
that i mean one possibility
what does this do right now
huh
seems fair
so i mean
that could generate an extensible list
lazy this one but i think in the same
ways with sparse arrays
like i think it should be its own you
know because one you might want finite
ones but also because i think that you
know with
right i mean as with sparserays it has
its own constructors and only if you
specifically ask first but you know it
very few functions
make this sort of decision where they
say oh i'm going to implicitly you know
i'm going to guess based on the
structure of my arguments that in this
case you really want to sparse right
here how many lazy constructors are you
proposing to have
probably like one
maybe two i mean lazy range for sure
and then otherwise nest list but nestles
could probably be repurposed to do it
anyway by just having a two argument
forum
but so what about lazy table
or lazy nest list how do you get i guess
table will be another another fine one
and
it's quite a small number
like there are a lot of operations but
there are many fewer uh
there are many fewer uh
structures
yeah and a lot of the constructors again
like a lot of those like nest list and
fixed point list and so on those are
ones where the argument structure would
be different if you had an infinite one
and where
there's there's really no reason
well
yeah yeah
so what are you suggesting are you
suggesting that two argument nest list
does the infinite case or are you
suggesting that um
uh instead there's a lazy nest list
well
i'm thinking about it i mean the
argument for
for
right i mean for example if we're taking
seriously the what about the finite case
then that would be an argument for
having the explicit lazy nest list
um but i'm not really sure how much the
function what would it even mean i mean
so
let's say we have this case
what would that mean what would it do
which you could reverse for example
i'm not sure reverse would be a
supportive operation for lazy lists but
at least this kind of lazy list for a
finite one you could do the reversal
you could but but i think you you really
can't for an infinite one so i'm not
sure it's worth supporting the operation
okay what difference does it make then
to have a finite one
i mean i can get total presumably on a
finite one as well
yeah i mean the reason i mean i i think
part of the reason why finite ones are
useful is for doing like indexing like
for example running take
why is that why is the finiteness useful
for that
well it just makes it i mean if you have
it so that take you know converts it
into a list i mean you end up with this
sort of weird situation with
right
here be an example right
so um
one of the standard ways of implementing
fibonacci this is like a classic piece
of haskell code
um which is you can make this
self-referential fibonacci where you
basically say
i think there's even an example on the
notebook on the right
uh if you scroll down just a little bit
um it's fib yeah fib two equals cons of
one cons of one
map thread plus
fib two and rest at fib two
okay so basically you're adding you know
the thing equals itself plus itself
shifted by one because of the rest
so should rest return a con an infinite
list or should it return
a
you know a quote-unquote finite one
it's returning infinite one right but
rest is kind of like an indexing
operation just like take and i i should
it should be possible to write take you
know two to infinity as well and and
have a similar thing happen so if two d
infinity returns an infinite list or you
know
whatever then i think or if rest returns
an infinite list then i think take comma
10 should also return the same structure
of thing it shouldn't be kind of
thinking about it and deciding well in
this case you know the the thing could
be unbounded so i'm going to return a
different type because it's kind of a
non-trivial thing to work out in what
cases it's going to be unbound in what
cases it's not
and you're claiming you could probably
make an undecided whether it's unbounded
or not i'm not sure if you really could
but i i just think it becomes hard to
reason about and you're going to end up
with weird unexpected stuff where you
know i have this input n and when n is
greater than 10 it returns an infinite
thing and when it's less than 10 it
returns a finite one and it's like i
don't i don't understand this i don't
understand what's the difference between
lazy range
of you know
zero comma ten
and range of zero comma ten other than
that
lazy range won't actually generate
anything in memory
no it'll generate a cons list or a lazy
list instead of rangers generates a list
i mean it's the same thing as saying
like what's the difference between
list one two three and sparse array of
one two three right so you're saying
the lazy range will actually give the
explicit list yes definitely
and again explain to me again why this
limiter is relevant
other than that
i mean what functionally is the
difference
between
i mean you're saying
so the limiter is relevant for for maybe
two reasons one reason is is this thing
about indexing that i think
you know if you can't have finite ones
then then indexing has to sometimes
return a finite one sometimes return
infinite one which can lead to all kinds
of weirdness the the other issue is that
i think there might be cases where you
want to have it be finite but lazy so so
an example would be this is more of a
programming example where i'm not sure
this is the best suited application but
but suppose i'm reading from a file the
file is finite but i want to do it
lazily because i want to kind of be
streaming in some way
um
you know
it's not infinite
yeah okay okay but fine so you can then
say length of the finite
although length is an is again kind of
uh
well no but i mean if you're going to
have finite ones you you want that
length should return infinity
in the case where it's an infinite list
it doesn't okay well
uh
that's super undecidable whether it's uh
it can ever return it can never return
infinity that's undecidable
even the even the the
you know
saying oh the length is 10 that's also
undecidable
well for a general
constructor function
i think we should try doing this
with a single lazy list construction
it's like just just think about
something like uh you know you make a
lazy range and you map primes over it
and you ask for length it's like
you clearly can't say infinity
or you know you select sorry select
prime cube
why isn't there still infinite number of
primes if i select twin primes then it's
kind of screwed well no but even even
yes there is infinite number of primes
but
it cannot possibly know that
and they can't possibly just look at
your program with a prime q in it and
say oh well there's infinitely many
primes so
i mean we do know that reduce knows that
for example
reduce knows that infinite primes
but again this this is coming back to
the different kinds of infinite lists
you might have and this is the thing
that we talked about in athena's project
was basically
if if we had uh you know
if we had a very different
representation of infinite lists then it
might make sense you know like the thing
where you know you have a function where
you give it a position and it gives you
the the value then it might make sense
to uh
you know
to to to do sort of mathematical
reasoning about it like that
but i think given this this
representation of infinite stuff or lazy
stuff i don't think that makes much
sense it's really hard to convert
between select of lazy range of you know
prime q and and a mathematical
expression and i don't think you could
possibly do it reliably but with another
representation you could
which is another reason why i don't
think any of these should really be in
system because
because
it's really not there's no right so one
path here that we have
is
just
is building a
lazy lists paclet which is kind of what
nick has already done here look at that
um
and uh
okay
in which there are tons of lazy
operations
yeah that's great
yeah
i like the graphic too
you can open a guide i have a little bit
more information there
what does all true
do that's the thing for
no no lazy all true i know what all true
does
but does lazy all true
consume a lazy list
yeah i assume it's a theorem
of some kind
is that true
i use it actually in the prime
definition you can just
on the on the on the left
so so out of curiosity and do do you so
first of all do you have finite lazy
lists or do you only use infinite ones
yeah i also have finally ten infinite
doesn't matter okay okay so so all true
can i'm just wondering if all true can
ever return false or sorry i can never
return true
but if you have finite ones then it can
so yeah
yeah but by the way do you know if do
you do something special with recursion
limit because i know there were issues
that i had where that seemed kind of
unavoidable
where you know you could you can
construct things where you can you can
recursion you can secrete it a little
bit you just your normal would just
basically append to an empty list until
until it can
so that there is no actual recursion
you just
unpeel the lazy structure slowly one by
one without recursing
i i tried to do something like that but
it still got mad at me but but maybe
maybe i was just doing it wrong i don't
remember the details because it was like
years ago but
yeah okay
may descend that's even if you have an
infinite lazy list if you
make normal of it it will think
indefinitely but if you abort it it will
just spit out
up to the point already computed
the normal list
wow
okay
with okay
given this
so in this strategy
where we're just making a paclet to do
this
um
well then you're about to describe how
it's useful for your pattern stuff
but
presumably we can make lazy nest graph
from this as well can't we
no no i'm not sure how yet i see how you
have a tree
but how the graph would be different
from a tree or something like that you
have just a nested
basically if you have a lazy list you
have a
arbitrary
nested
list of lazy lists and so on and you can
just traverse it arbitrarily
and graph would be just when you have
some kind of
equivalence between things
which is just a crazy list again but
that's turning a graph into a dag
basically
yeah
and i think that
you know
okay let's look at your pattern matching
stuff
so what is this doing
what is pattern substitutions
this is
what i want to return a lazy structure
or generator of things it's like this
returns a
some kind of lazy pink that you can
traverse
and it contains two different
heads
as a sum and
product we already looked at it last
time yeah we looked at this
so
now just
output all the matches or
whatever number you can provide but if
you just return that like a generator i
could just traverse it and if i because
pattern much is
inherently recursive i can use it
in the definition of all the pattern
objects easily
if i just want a single result i can
just ask it for a single result and it
will do it
naturally and efficiently without
traversing every possible combination of
much
and so on well so i mean from a
practical point of view for users
this can be an opaque box
you don't even know how far the laziness
has gone
that this would return rather than
returning this you just return a summary
box here yeah which is just a lazy
generator
internally that's what it can be yep but
now
so
that would represent
that thing
would return something that represents
all substitutions with this thing on
that
why is it called patent substitution why
isn't it called matches
because then
the substitution bindings is essentially
a property of the matches
what other functions maybe it could have
caught much as i don't know
i don't remember why i called it that
you have a guide here as well
it's just a
function of
for example substitution applied that
takes this substitution and applies it
to a pattern to reconstruct an original
expression that it matched against
and if you apply much
and doesn't make sense to apply a match
to a pattern i don't know
substitution basically is an idea that
holds every
substitution and binding binding is a
kind of
special version of substitution
okay i'm i'm confused here the the big
picture
of what we're doing here
is
we're defining for a replacement
for a
you know we're saying we've got an
expression we are going to apply a
replacement based on some pattern
what are all the possible ways in which
the pattern can match
it is the case that
in doing a substitution
you never need to know about the right
hand side to determine whether the
pattern will match is that true or not
true
i remember there was some weird cases
back in the day which we may have
cauterized that had to do with like
default arguments and things
where there were cases where
you simply couldn't determine the right
hand side
where there was a nominal match but it
couldn't determine the right hand side
i'm saying so we so we just decided to
make those not match
so we never had the issue of having the
undetermined right-hand side
i don't think it's the issue now
okay well wear it
okay
but so what's the big picture of what
will be done here
so
i mean you have many
substitution bindings okay
um
those are interesting but i mean
okay so what go ahead well one of the
things i also wanted to achieve with the
pattern things
uh is to be to be able to
easily
make custom patterns it's like
what if a user wants
to have it like his own pattern
so i don't understand what
god
i just want to like be
make it possible to make an old pattern
of things easily
and
you know
you and basically how would use it it's
just to make a sub value for your part
and object for pattern substitutions
so that it produces this generator
do we have a single example of where you
want to do this
well i don't have but i have plans like
for example
i wanted some kind of pattern that
is a tool to alternatives in a way or
not it does alternate so it's like very
close to options but for arbitrary
things
options pattern basically it takes a
list of patterns that you wanna match
against some sub subset of it
right it works for rules and it went
kind of the same pattern but
just
matches against subset rules some sort
of expressions or whatever so if you
wanna define it you basically make your
pattern substitutions
for this new object
so it's a little bit like repeated of
alternatives kind of or no because you
can't have repeats or something
well i mean a naive case would be
something like g i'm sorry double blank
blank g
that is everything or blank blank i mean
the
the options pattern must be very similar
to double blank rule
well it's not because you can have
arbitrarily uh nested lists around it
and so on
also do triple blank but yeah
okay
but okay but so i'm still trying to
understand here what was the thing that
we were trying to solve originally
we want to be able to take
original objective is
we're trying to be able to generalize
things like trace graph to the
multi-computational case
so what you have here
is something that is the core
of a replace list all the way down
but as we've discussed previously
i mean
for the pattern matcher
it's a multi-output function
for most built-in functions they're not
multi-output
but
okay i mean the with the way we make
so you know multi-wayness
of typical evaluations
can be achieved by just uh
by allowing all possible evaluation
orders
does that make sense
yeah basically you can evaluate any
unhealth sub-expression
or at least
if i have this
i want a transformation where this has
been made into f x b c d
f a x c d and so on
i mean that's the difference between
you know
if we imagine sort of physics project
type stuff
that's the difference between you take
the whole of the
you know the whole hypograph
and you rewrite it all at once versus
you can rewrite any subpart
anytime you want
by what happened to your compile
everything to hypographs
concept neck
no it's
it's there
it's not developed much further
i have some
like general
causal graphs
and basically that's it that's enough
but you know it's a summer school
project though of compiling a whole
bunch of stuff
yes
yeah yeah yeah
would you have this project
combining different
computations how far did that get
i mean i think he had he had you know
dfa's nfa's turning machines
non-deterministic turn machines some
like
tags no register machines or something
and then he even had some
i think he had some very basic kind of
interpreted lisp like language or
something that he compiled to
some kind of
complicated language basically small
version of assembler there is a bunch of
instructions
okay
so what we learn from that
that is a way of making everything be
able to have a meaningful causal graph
because we've broken things down to the
eems as we might say and really had
speak
um
we've successfully broken down
everything into eames
and to
and and therefore
because we can trace eames we can know
what the causal graph is
yeah yeah
and so
can i ask what is an eem
it's an atom of existence
so it's the lowest level thing
in the model of space that we have there
are atoms of space
that have relations that are defined by
the hypergraph
so an eem is a generalization of that
idea it's an atom of existence
in the notion of atoms in computer data
structures it is the ultimate such atom
and the only thing that you can say
about an eem
is
that it's different from another from
all other eames
and that it exists
yeah yeah
it's just a fundamental unit of
computation that we tend to use when
we're speaking globally about
computations like when we do
multi-computation for instance
right so this is basically
compiling down to edens
in a way
that because wolfram language for
example has
the notion of you know functions with
arguments
that's higher level than eames
this is it is
okay
traditional mathematical logic
and mathematical notation
has the idea of variables and
quantifiers and things like that
one could compile all of that stuff down
into eams into some kind of uniform
representation layer and i think what
we're talking about is compiling
um
you know wolverine language stuff which
also has like
traditional
axiomatic formulations in mathematical
logic has a certain amount more
structure than the pure sort of emic
structure
you know
right it's it's in a sense
you know something like lisp perhaps
would have slightly less structure
and the trade-off is the less structure
you have the more incomprehensible it is
to humans
um
but i think that's the the idea is to
compile it to something completely
uniform
i mean we could as well
perhaps compile to turing machines but i
think that hypergraphs are more
convenient than turing machines
do people agree with this
characterization
yeah ubiquitous
is what
they're ubiquitous you can convert
anything to them very easily
right you can run i think the turing
machines is rather hard in many cases
it's much more powerful
okay but so for example in ian's
uh trace graph stuff
could we okay we could represent every
expression as a
hypercraft we can represent every
variable
that is defined through the symbol table
as a shared
atom of existence in this hypergraph is
that a true statement
yeah right here
basically a variable
is a
it's kind of yeah it depends where you
have this atom
as a part of a rule or part of a
hypergraph itself
so we kind of have to distinguish
between patterns by variables and just
expressions
yes
well except in the matter mathematics
project we found a way to merge those
two things together
i mean you can either put a little bit
more sophistication into the laws of
inference
or you can say what you just said
basically you can convert an expression
or a pattern to a hypergraph
yes
okay but but were you two
convert the expressions in ian's trace
graph the hypergraphs
then we can immediately produce a causal
graph
correct
just by tracing eames
yeah correct
and it is slightly unclear how we
produce the causal graph
from the wolfram language expressions
also true statement
you mean they're directly or for the
cryptographic compilation no directly
yeah that's
kind of yeah
unclear right now there might be more
than one way to compile a wolfram
language expression into hypergraphs
well it depends how it also represented
internally if you just have all the
symbols in the expression mapped to some
internal memory that basically memory
addresses it's like
yes
well and the only thing that's in there
is punch pointers
yeah so just trace the pointers it's the
same as tracing eems
yes
but again once we've said that one of
the key things is that because
because everything has a place the
causality of things
is clear because there's there's no
notion of
you can't make a copy of a thing it
either is at the same place or it
doesn't or it isn't the same thing
right
that's why there's a well-defined
causality
i mean the difficulty for causality
usually
is that
you can end up i mean this is a this is
a standard issue i mean you can end up
with
uh
right i mean this is a famous case right
if we do the following thing
if we say x x equals n of
blah blah blah
comma
50.
okay actually i just and now i say
xx minus xx
am i doing the right thing
then the whole point is that those are
how do i do this there's a way of doing
this work basically
the question of whether it's the same
number
it can be
the number that is represented the same
way
with n
but it isn't the same number like
this making any sense to anybody
let me say it again
in numerical round-off
right we could have two numbers
that have the same representation
but they come from two completely
different places
so if you subtract them
the correct thing to do is to give a
number that is of order their precision
you know order
that 10 to the minus whatever that
precision is
if on the other hand both those numbers
really did come from the same place
when you subtract them they should you
should get zero
because you know they're the same
yeah
right so this question
about
absent the idea so the whole point is
there is no meaningful sense with your
eames with addresses
there is no meaningful numbers couldn't
be the same unless they were in the same
does that place sense
sure
in other words there is no
okay
in
in a world where
everything
is eams
there are no literals
right there's no string literals there's
no number literals they're all just you
know the two there is a unique two in
the world
i right
they have to be unique
right and once they're unique causality
is easy to trace
yeah i agree with this
um
so that's really the main thing we're
achieving
by emifying
aka
hypographic everything
is that then
we have squashed out any literals
um
but the overall objective of this again
was
you know right now the only
multi-weighing
okay there are two kinds of
multi-weighing that i can see
in ian's
trace graph
one is whenever there's pattern matching
you could match in all possible ways
and the other is
you can use all possible evaluation
orders
am i making sense i mean there are other
things which in principle functions that
right now return one argument could be
one value could be redefined to return
multiple values
yeah like
x can have
multiple own values
yes and this is where the multi-concept
comes in
and right right now the only way of
multiplying things so to speak
um as opposed to multiplying multiplying
is through the pattern matcher
values
basically
even
like there could be multiple down values
that match the pattern and then the
pattern itself can much multiple results
yes yes yes yes yes yes
um
okay
how does
multiness
arise
okay so
thing number one
multiple pattern matching multiple
pattern matches
all right although if you're talking
about things like down values i would
argue that
there is a
i mean
down values are not multi-way because
there's a way of choosing which is the
most specific one
[Music]
right if there is there might not be
well on the off check i mean first of
all just a practical level you'd like to
be able to do multi-way things even you
know
you might not want to have to guarantee
that all the the down values that you
want to sort of non-determine
particularly between
are are exactly the same specificity
because that would be very annoying and
people don't know how that works
um
but
yeah
yeah that's practically how we program
we have to
order the down values in order for them
to return the desired result
right i i'm just saying you know
obviously it makes sense to talk about
basically the replace list like idea but
um
i think that it's
you know
it requires it's not the same thing as
just down values because down values do
have a you know canonical way of
choosing one well so does replace so
does pattern matching
right but we're sort of ripping apart
the concept of a down value i think by
by doing that like down values basically
called replace
and and and the other oh i understand
this is a multi-down value this is not a
down value this would be good but but
also if you have down values and if you
have down values of existing functions
it often makes no sense to apply them
non-deterministically i mean everything
else you know you might have to fall
through error cases defined or something
so right that's it
look evaluation orders for sub
expressions might also not make sense
like the sub expression could be you
know compound expression and then it
would absolutely not make sense to do
things in different orders
but so in other words each of these has
to be done with care
yeah i'm just saying i'm not sure it
makes sense to to literally take get the
multiness by looking at down values of
that of f
well i don't think any of these make
sense i mean look there are plenty of
pieces of code
where multi-pattern matches will give
wrong answers
the non-leading pattern match will be
the wrong answer
just like the non-leading evaluation
order will be the wrong answer
you know i think this is
this is essentially what one might
picturesquely call quantizing code
not just going down the
the primary classical path
but allowing all possible paths
and i agree that much much code cannot
be quantized without just blowing up in
all kinds of crazy ways
but the thing i keep on saying
for nick and everybody else's benefit
is we need these functions that are the
things that observe interesting
properties of quantized code
of multi-way code
you know find replace path for instance
and and nick can you explain
okay so there are these ways of
generating multiness
of which probably the cleanest
is this pattern matching based one
you can also have an explicit multiness
like if you have a rule that explicitly
returns multiple results yeah okay
okay so then there's okay
right
ie multi
that's that's the explicit version and
by the way the pattern matcher could
return a multi any of these things could
return a multi
yeah
right and then the question of i mean do
you have multis implemented
because one one obvious question is as
um equivalencing for multis
like for example if a multi returns
has multiple graphs in it does it do
graph isomorphism
well
it should be just graphism
it should also compare the actual
the actual values right what's the point
just
comparing graphs
maybe so but i think it would be good
did you implement multi yet i mean look
it seems to me that we really need
okay
multiple pattern matches we need a
version of replace you know we need
something that's called essentially
replace multi
but instead of returning a list returns
a multi
and then
you know i think replace repeated
multi
is basically the evaluator give or take
yeah well my music kind of
worked
what it was capable of is capable of
if you provided an expression it just
searches for all the down values and it
tries to apply all of them okay but so
that's one form of multiness
yeah also you can
make an explicit list of rules or just a
list of explicit values
and you can
combine them
okay but that's enough
in the end
we're going to generate a multi
which will probably be lazy
and then we're going to ask certain
things about the multi just like we're
asking certain things about lazy lists
except that in the case of the multi
one of the things we want to ask is the
proof path
yeah multi is an example of a waste
generator that's yeah that's a nice
analogy
a which generator lazy generator you can
yes
yes but i mean my point is that what we
want to extract from a multi
you know in a lazy generator
one of the things that's there is
information about history
or potentially there
and in a multi we often want that that
information about history because it's
the it's the proof basically
right
so for example multi object that i have
have a property that first of all
returns uh like edges basically that you
would use in a
causal graph or a space graph
you can just run instead of
producing edges you can just run it and
produce a next module object that just
contains all the the next hypersurface
basically
yes right so every multi defines a
hypersurface
yeah
and what's not totally obvious is given
one multi
as you evolve that multi you have to
define what foliation you're going to
use to say which type of surface you get
next
well if multi yeah basically
right
because if you just apply the all the
possible without all the possible rules
that it contains with all the possible
values
what would you pick for your next
hypersurface exactly
exactly
so you have to put
the other ones somewhere
i think multi always have some canonical
canonical order
canonical foliation basically because it
always
have just apply once whatever rule
whatever pattern matching just apply it
once but where which one do you do once
what if they
overlap well you just
anyway if their web will try all
possible overlaps
that's all the sources of motion you can
try and you can okay all together
just
and that will just provide
the new hypersurface
there's no kind of ambiguity where to
turn you can
prune them afterwards yeah okay
but nothing else i think
let's try and get so i think this this
description of types of multiness is
useful
because some of them are more controlled
than others
i mean
let's try to get implementations of some
of this but then again i keep on asking
for the thing that takes out a multi
the things we care about like for
example given a set of rules
you know how do we apply these rules so
that we get a result with certain
characteristics if it's possible
right
all right we should probably wrap up
here
um
kind of late for something else
um
we're making progress here guys we're
making progress
and nick i mean do you feel like you
have a definite direction of
of how to go multi with these things
well now i see
just
okay after i
play it out play around with laziness
because i still think my kind of view of
the completely different
i would i would treat
because i still want this like to work
some functions that work on arbitrary
health arguments i held
symbols and so on well fine i mean look
i think we're giving up for now on the
idea of a single
point of laziness so to speak and we're
agreeing that that there should be a
whole packlet's worth of
stuff yeah
so i think you're you know what you're
building is in fine alignment with that
now what was the other thing you were
saying
and then this much object can be
viewed as one of the generators of lazy
graph
and then i will look at what can be done
with it
yeah
all the traversals of graphs can be
lasified but when your lazy object is a
multi
something
indeed indeed because every slice of the
graph is a multi
although i
claim you actually need to know in that
well i mean it's a question of how the
graph is traversed
and maybe we start with dags
well that's what
that would
would mean to lazify function so if you
have breadth first scan and therefore
scan you
lazy versions would actually traverse
this multi-thing
in a
in the corresponding
order yes i mean the lazy thing doesn't
define the order it's when you actually
start evaluating the lazy thing that you
have to define the order yeah so the
functions define how they would
generate use this generating object
well the multi could be thought of as
like
an intermediate state and a multi-way
system
a multi is laid out in branch hill space
and that's another way useful way to
look at it perhaps
whereas a list or even a lazy list might
be laid out in list space so to speak in
one dimensional list space
a multi is laid out in branch shell
space
yeah
so basically multi can contain lazy
lists inside of it
so the result of that applying
generating values for multi can be just
represented by laser list and then you
can just pick first result
of any lazy list that would be a depth
first order
if you just traverse all the lazy list
on the hyper surface that would be
upgrade first
sure
well and it's a lazy list in the sense
that there is a canonical ordering of
the eems
in this or whatever they are of the of
the expressions that you get
inside the multi
in in the slice of the graph assuming
you've got an index graph and you've
labeled every node of the graph then i
agree with you that it's a lazy list of
elements that represent one
current
kind of orthogonal to time hypersurface
does that make sense
yeah and you can
well you can the outside functions for
multi can control the the water in the
laser list how they are generated
so much contains all the rules and the
all the
metal rules how to apply those in any
different order that you would
want to ask of it
that's fine i mean if you want to do it
that way yeah right that's fine the
multi the multi already i mean it
the multi by being a foliated by being a
hypersurface
knows what kind of a hypersurface it was
and how it was derived
is what you're saying
well i can imagine a disembodied
generator of the graph that does not yet
have foliation information
i don't think like multi necessarily
should contain the history
it's whatever uses it and traverses it
should contain it
okay well again i really think we need
to do this exercise where we've got the
space-like multi-type thing you've got a
time-like path
you've got to be able to extract those
things
are we going to be able to extract the
list of multis
that will be essentially
well okay we got the list of multis
which are the contents of the
hypersurfaces context of the anti-chains
we've also got the branchial graph of
any multi
right any multi should have a branchial
graph i climb
yeah okay if if it knows the history or
how it was applied
produced how it was produced yes
and um
but i mean so i think what needs to be
done is we've got to define
for those different sources of multiness
how to generate the maltese
yeah and then
not only how to generate the multis but
also how to trace things like
the
proof path
now maybe those traces
have to be from things like trace graph
maybe you have to have a maybe there's
an evaluation process that gives you a
series of multis
and you have to explicitly trace to know
the history of the maltese
see what i'm saying
i mean like in standard wolfram language
it's an answers only system it does not
give you a trace of how it got there
for that you need to use trace
or trace graph or whatever
yeah i think it's enough to move for
multi to just
contain the output results and the
events that produce them with just the
events basically if the multi was a
container not of expression states but a
container for events
so then you are storing history in the
multi yeah but only one level
so it's like
why it wasn't one only the one level
because it goes back to another multi
oh yeah i don't think you need to i
can't
store all of them right it's like the
initial multi can just contains the like
all the initial
states with some initial event that
produced them if you generate a new
multi object it just contains all the
events that can
so it's kind of like a linked list of
multis
every multi refers to a previous multi
yeah if you just you you can make a
linked list of this it's one of the
operations they kept yeah
right so it's like time as a linked list
you know computational irreducibility
implies that time is a linked list in
some sense
yeah
yeah
basically multi is also
spatial
hyper spatial hyperservice
yes
if you just if it's just a container for
events
for the most recent events
i mean you could represent it by the
previous multi plus a bunch of events
or in principle you could represent it
by a very distant past multi plus a
bunch of events
i think you need to implement some of
these
i think you need to implement multi plus
for goodness sake let's implement some
of these operations that we've so long
talked about like find replace path
on multi is constructed by some of these
methods
okay
i mean what i find interesting
conceptually here
is you know we have classical
computation which is the one pathway of
doing things
in sort of the texture of how one gets
to quantum mechanics
involving coats quotes quantization
which is
you know the texture of what we have to
do here is very similar
right of of we add all these possible
paths
and then we have equivalencing between
paths
which is
its own operation
and
let's see when we've got these different
paths
yeah i mean
i'm making the guess that something like
destructive interference
okay here's a bizarre claim okay let's
say you have an error case in a
collection of down values
as soon as you go quantum
you have the possibility of exciting
that error case even though just because
it's one of the possible unless you lock
the error case
by having you know by saying only if
this happens do you do it as opposed to
just saying it's one of the gang one of
the collection but you wouldn't normally
get to it in the classical operations
sure
yeah
then
in a sense
the error case is a piece of probability
so to speak a piece of amplitude
that sort of escapes into the into the
you know goes off into the sunset
as opposed to most operations that stay
in this region that
is the one that you are seriously going
to observe
you know as opposed to going off into
this into the sunset by with this weird
case that you're not interested in
you know there's going to be some
analogy here
no the the only analogy i think it's
okay multiple system is
if you want to interpret quantum
mechanics it's
mostly
many world interpretations similar right
so you as soon as you have events or
rule applications that overlap that's
when the world split
yeah and
you define your measurement is some kind
of rule that can exist on both branches
right but the key difference between
many worlds and this
is that
we imagine that the brain is also many
welded
right in other words the observer is
part of the system the observer is not
just sitting on one branch
yeah it's a part of the systems so that
the similar rule that has the observer
and the thing that the observer measures
can be applied in both branches and
because branches are different than
different results
yeah
yeah the observer spans many branches
the observer is quite big in branch hill
space
right yeah basically
the part of an observer
contained in both branches
and the if the rule matches
em of an observer and imover system
branches measurement on different
branches have different results and we
would say if the system contains some
kind of phase
yes would
can be
destructively interfered so
yes
all right we're getting there this is
more to do okay i think we have a path
here
and um uh
several
right
um
okay
good stuff
well
thanks and um
to be continued this is very exciting
stuff in my opinion
and we're
um
you know
we're really making progress i think and
nick then we really need to yeah i mean
i'm i'm convinced you you've done
something reasonable in this
implementation
of the lazy paclet
which should make it to the packet
repository
and um
uh
let's see some multi stuff here
um
you know evaluation orders and observers
are going to need to be
made computable here and that's what
that i think is what we're going to run
into next
we already talked about some of the
evaluation orders stuff but with more to
come okay to be continued
um
all right
thanks guys see you later